One way you can narrow down the topics for your interview is
by looking at the job descriptions for each position you apply to.
If C++ is a primary language listed,
you'll be best served by practicing in this.
If not, lean toward the language of the companies you're most interested in.
Make sure if you list a programming language on your resume,
you're prepared to answer a question with it.
Companies want to measure your proficiency in what you've listed.
Also, if there's a responsibility or minimum requirement listed for the job,
expect that to be a potential area of questioning in the interview.
Before your interview, you should also consider asking
your recruiter who you will interview with and what the topics of the interview will be.
That might first narrow down what you need to prepare for.
Let's walk through a recent job posting for
a machine learning and computer vision engineer to see what we can gather.
To start, most companies put some information
at the top about what the company and team does.
Make sure you know this information and do some research on your own as well.
You'll definitely get asked why you're interested in this company
and often get asked on what you know about what the company does.
You want to be able to give an answer that goes
deeper than just common knowledge about the company.
This may not have been apparent from the job title alone,
but this rule actually relates their mapping and localization team as
well but in applying machine learning and computer vision toward it.
So, you'll want to prepare for the primary roles topics,
the localization and mapping will also likely be an area of this interview.
Now that we're to their responsibilities section,
we can tell SLAM,
computer vision and machine learning are part of the normal responsibilities or the role.
It also mentions staying current with the latest research, visiting conferences,
et cetera, which means you'll either be asked about
some recent papers you've read or conferences you've attended.
Alternatively, you should bring these up in
your interview if you feel you stand out in this area.
The last two responsibilities in deploying
production code and working with international teams,
will likely be a question of explaining the time you've done so, if applicable.
Showing why you're a great teammate is important for any role.
Let's move to experience and skills.
If you made it past a phone screen and onto a technical interview,
it typically means you have at least met
the minimum experience and skills they want to see for the position.
We can still utilize this for
some predictions of questions you might be asked for this role.
Again, we see a mention of recent research.
So, be prepared to talk about anything you've read lately in the area.
Next, a key item here is listing out
various deep learning and machine learning algorithms.
You'll likely be asked to code something using one of these libraries.
Next up, it mentions mathematical skills.
So, you may be asked to solve a fairly complex mathematical problem.
This may be fairly far reaching but it's
likely related to a problem in machine learning or mapping,
based on what we've seen so far.
Lastly, it mentions algorithms in C++ which is another reminder for
you that this autonomous systems interview course is just one piece of the puzzle here.
Many jobs also have a nice to have or ways to stand out section.
Here, we see mapping,
geometry, robotics, and autonomous driving technology.
If you've taken one of our nano degree programs in autonomous systems,
you have experience in each of these.
Make sure to both highlight these on your resume and to bring them up in
your interview even if you aren't specifically asked directly about them.